now what i want to work out is these
four things let's get all the
information down
and then let's work out in terms of
rather than the language that they give
us
like we have all these fancy labels that
are sort of helpful markers for us what
are we trying to work out
so they don't give you much information
do they um they say okay it's it's
uniform
circular motion that's nice it doesn't
look at the same ring to it as
simple harmonic motion but anyway you'll
get used to it it's uniform circular
motion
you've got a um a radius of two
and it's traveling at 80 revolutions per
minute which by the way turns out to be
very important in a second okay
now what are we trying to work out part
a they want angular velocity what's our
name for angular velocity
omega good so we'll work out that in a
second
b they want the speed speed how do you
work out
speed
it's going to be now there's a change in
angle but then we want the change in the
arc length
so getting to our clip you're just going
to be multiplying by the radius
it's not very hard okay that makes sense
yes no okay see
the magnitude of the acceleration so you
got
acceleration but you just want the
magnitude just the size
okay and then the last thing you want
the period
okay let's go through them one by one
that's an a
sorry how do we work out and give a lot
of um velocity
well you've got it going around 80 times
per minute
right 80 times per minute let's take
that as our starting point
all right now every revolution how many
radians is it going around the answer is
2 pi
right so 80 revolutions is really code
for 80
times 2 pi radians okay
so now i've got an angle and then i can
work towards an angular velocity okay
now this is um per minute but i don't
want it to be per minute right and your
velocity omega our units for omega are
radians
per second radians per second
and that's why you have to divide okay
so this is really
160 pi radians over
60 seconds right so then you divide
through
what do you get 80 on eight on three
eight on three because i've got a zero
don't know
eight pi on three radians
per second happy with that no big deal
okay let's move on part b
wait yes no yeah okay i didn't want to
move on if you're not clear
okay um how do i get speed speed
that's just r omega isn't it and i know
what r
is it's two so it's just going to be two
pi sorry 16 pi on three now
what unit will i have
well it's um it's two meters right
meters i should have probably put that
off there right
and the great thing about you using
radians is that you don't need to do any
conversions
right this is already now meters per
second okay
all right now part c to get to
acceleration
how did we get acceleration before we
went all the way from
like displacement velocity acceleration
and so on how do i get acceleration here
who's gotten it hands up i won't ask you
but who's got an answer for this
good okay anyone else go i'm gonna get
you to pause two
two is not good enough okay i want you
to go back in your notes
we already developed this go back go
back there haven't been that many notes
under circular motion
see if you can find it where is it
have you found it i know not everyone
was here yesterday
but the people who were here yesterday
it should be there in black and white
isn't it just r omega squared yes
yeah okay it's not that hard right so
all you're doing
is you're taking this value you've
already worked out right so there's my
radius
times omega squared
whatever that works out to be i don't
know 2 times
64 128 pi squared
on nine yes
now um it asks for magnitude what units
have i got here
meters per second squared
cool done last bit and after the period
how long
how long does it take is that what i
asked the period of motion how long does
it take to go around
okay and we worked out this before right
you've got two pi radians to go
in total for one revolution and you
divide by
your angular velocity right omega
so it's going to be two pi all over
eight pi
on three let's see
that's a four cancel cancel cancel
cancel three quarters
seconds does that make sense as a number
does that sound about right does it
sound accurate does it sound in the
picture
i think it does right you've got 60
seconds the clock
the time it goes and then it goes and
when it rounds down
it's going around 80 times right so it
has to take less than a second to go all
the way around
it's not that long okay